Da bros of the world. Are you dumb,
stupid, or dumb? Huh? Or maybe just
insane. Shutman's da buddy, a failed
rapper and now full-time snitch named
Malik, recently started attacking God
Logic's wife. Malik, much like Shikman,
is too much of a coward to debate God
logic like a man. So he attacked his
wife like the sniveling coward he's been
his entire life. Classic Dawa move. It's
the same thing Muhammad Hijab did years
ago. So I responded the same way to the
coward Malik as I did to the coward
Muhammad Hijab. I pointed out that if
the DA clowns are going to cross that
line and attack people's wives and
families, I too will cross a line and
come up with all kinds of creative ways
to desecrate the Quran. So I let them
decide how we're going to proceed.
Shikman's Dawa buddy Malik could have
simply apologized like a man with
integrity and we would have been done.
But he didn't. He decided he chose to
continue attacking God Logic's wife. And
on top of that, he doxed my wife. He
posted her phone number and our home
address on Tik Tok. My wife got more
than a dozen creepy phone calls around
midnight telling her it's over now. Not
to mention creepy text messages telling
her she'd better start looking for a
Muslim husband. And Malik pulled this
stunt when he knew I was out of town. So
what should I do now? Should I throw in
the towel? Should I raise the white
flag? Should I beg for mercy? Should I
surrender?
My wife's the one they're harassing
right now. Big strong jihadis. So, I
guess I should let her decide. If she
wants me to back down, I'll back down.
Let me see what she thinks.
Do these clowns really think this will
make us back down. Laughing emoji. We
won't back down until we're dead.
Oh my goodness. This woman is crazy. No
wonder she married a psychopath. So,
backing down is apparently frowned upon
by my entire family. But it's okay
because I've got a better idea. Don't
worry about my wife and kids being safe
today. I sent my brother John over to
keep an eye on things. John, like the
Dizzle, grew up in a West Virginia
trailer park, and anyone from a West
Virginia trailer park can smack around
10 Giadis blindfolded. So, my family's
okay today. I'll be flying home tonight
after my live stream with Jai and DOC.
No nurse tonight. So, I'll stay up all
night with our son Paley.
I'll go to sleep for a few hours in the
morning, then wake up, go to church,
come home, and fry up some tender,
delicious bacon wrapped Kuran pages.
Then I'll feed those bacon wrapped Quran
pages to the worst excuse for a dog I've
ever seen in my entire life, a
pink-eared poodle. A day or two later,
that pink- eared poodle will answer the
call of nature and leave what's left of
those bacon wrapped Quran pages in the
yard, at which point I'll pick up those
doggy dew covered Quran bits with, you
guessed it, some pages of the Quran.
That will be my first contribution to a
little project I'm starting in Malik's
honor. Would you like to join me in my
little project? If so, I invite you to
come up with some creative ways of
desecrating the Quran. Right after Malik
doxed my family, a woman told me that
she's been waiting years for a reason to
cover pages of the Quran with her
menstrual blood. I said, "Well, there's
no way people would know it's really
menstrual blood. So, any blood would
work unless it's fake blood like the
kind Shake Uman Iben Smlette squirted on
himself when he faked that hate crime."
But she said, "No, I'd have to cut
myself for any other blood, so I'd
rather use real menstrual blood." And I
dropped my objection.
Anywh who, you get the idea. Send me
your videos of your most creative ways
of desecrating the Quran. Don't show
yourself. You don't want Malik and
Central Da and Shikman's other pals
doxing you and harassing you and
threatening your family members. So keep
yourselves out of your videos and just
send them to me. Again, be creative.
Animals are always a big hit with dawa
guys in more ways than one. Animals
eating the Quran, using the Quran as a
toilet, and so on. All good ideas.
Speaking of toilets, toilets are also a
good idea. Any of you gun guys out
there, you know what to use for target
practice. Power tools, swords, knives,
shredders, blenders, you name it. Get
creative. Surprise me. After all
submissions are in, I'll pick the best
ones and put them all together in an
amazing video titled top 100 ways to
desecrate the Quran, sponsored by Dr.
Malik, the Msad Agent. And that will
just be the beginning. 2026 is going to
be off the chain, ladies and gentlemen.
As for you, Malik,
how about you stop hiding on Tik Tok
like the pathetic little [__] you are
and come get me, coward. And you'd
better bring an army because trust me on
this one. You don't want to go down in
history as just the failed rapper who
caused the most epic campaign of Quran
desecration the world has ever seen.
That's not what you want to be
remembered for. You want at least some
redemption after embarrassing the ummah,
snitching on absolutely everyone, and
deliberately causing all this Quran
desecration.
So bring an army
unless your MSAD handlers won't let you.
Talk to you tomorrow, cupcake.
on that. You tried on that. You just
backfig.
There's a reason to it. Yeah. Yeah.